le bétel jeu 50 morts toujours pas
d'explication à la catastrophe
cambodge le prince tianhu qui arrive
tout à l'heure à l'onu à new york
devraient et guichard les tiraillements
du rpr à propos de l'europe là messieurs
bonsoir la catastrophe du bételgeuse
aura donc fait 50 morts cet irlandais la
totalité d'équipage français parmi eux
25 breton qui laisseront trente deux
orphelins on a appris tout à l'heure que
les corps ne serait probablement pas
rapatriée en france il paraît que la loi
française s'oppose au rapatriement de
personnes dont l'identité surtout la
nationalité n'aurait pu être confirmée
alors bien sûr on nous dira que
l'identification est pratiquement
impossible vu la violence de l'explosion
mais tout de même il ya là quelque chose
de choquant et d'injuste le président
giscard d'estaing viennent demander à
son ministre des transport joël le
theule de faire toute la lumière sur
cette catastrophe et de lui transmettre
rapidement les conclusions de son
enquête
une enquête qui sera très difficile si
j'en crois notre envoyé spécial dans la
baie de braintree claude gaignierre qui
vient de nous transmettre son reportage
sur le gaignierre qui a suivi à l'aube
les premiers enquêteurs
mardi matin 9 heures trente six heures
après l'accident nous sommes sereins
petit remorqueur avec le président de la
compagnie française total compagnie
française de navigation des experts du
ministère des transports pour savoir
qu'est ce qui a pu se passer sur le pt 2
quand nous sommes arrivés ce matin
premières constatations l'arrière du
navire avait disparu la sombre et
pendant la nuit
ici tout le monde s'interroge on ne
comprend pas comment cet accident a pu
arriver
quelles sont les responsabilités c'est
pour ça d'ailleurs que les experts sont
ici regardez regardez
et effectivement ils ne comprennent pas
comment d'un seul coup car en trois
marins français se sont littéralement
volatilisé parmi eux le commandant de
bord celui qui avait conduit le bateau
jusqu'ici et celui qui devait le
commander après des piles en béton fondu
sous la chaleur tout est carbonisé noir
on a retrouvé jusqu'à présent que 18
corps un seul a été identifié une femme
les pouces d'un officier quatre
irlandais ont été retrouvés dans une
sorte d' à brive les avait essayé de se
réfugier aux aguets carbonisés ce matin
les experts français cherchent ils nous
demanderont après cette inspection que
nous avons fait avec lui au président de
la compagnie française
s'il a pu se faire une opinion donc je
dois dire qu'il est absolument
impossible le moment d'avoir une opinion
sur les raisons de l'accident
je voudrais dire tout de suite pour moi
aujourd'hui la véritable tragédie parce
que je dirais l'unique travay 10 et la
perte des vies humaines
je pense d'abord aux familles de nos
marins et cruellement éprouvée ainsi qu
aux familles irlandaises et qui ont
perdu certains de leurs parents dans la
catastrophe mais cette émotion une fois
passé est bien compréhensible du jabra
effectivement une querelle d'experts et
est-ce qu'on peut établir et ce qui est
une faute humaine est ce que c'est une
faute de matériel est ce que vous avez
une équité là encore je ne vois pas ce
que je pourrais vous répondre
aujourd'hui
malheureusement il n'ya plus de témoins
comme vous le savez deux incidents
puisque la totalité de d'équipage a
disparu dans la catastrophe
ainsi que tout le personnel qui se
trouvait qui se trouvait sur l'acheter
en ce qui nous concerne nous n'avons
absolument aucune idée sur ce qui a bien
pu causer cet accident qui pour nous est
quelque chose d'absolument incroyable
avec les plans du bétel jeux et des
photos prises par les journalistes et
publiée par la presse on essaie de
comprendre car maintenant il va falloir
établir ses responsabilités et déjà la
champagne américaine gulf qui gère le
terminal déclare que le bateau n'était
pas à elle
le pétrole non plus et qu'elle n'est
donc pas responsable d'autres se
demandent pourquoi le navire français
n'étaient pas équipés du système de gaz
inerte qui permet d'éviter quand les
cubes se vident d'avoir à l'intérieur un
mélange détonnant aux explosifs
en fait le président des catégories et
là me confie j'ai échangé des pompes et
envahit vont value c'est un navire qui à
l'époque à laquelle est construit
répondait aux normes les plus modernes
de sécurité et qui continuait à les
remplir
en ce qui concerne cette catégorie de
navires donc faire d'une un équipement
du navire une installation de gaz inerte
problème ou alimentant des polémiques
est à mon avis un faux problème et je
tiens à la firme et avec beaucoup de
fermeté
là il s'agit d'une très mauvaise
querelle alors des vins de france est
sur un bateau français ont-ils commis
des erreurs
jacques lynch le premier ministre
irlandais venu hier à benfica il a
promis une enquête
un procès va être ouvert le problème
pourtant et c'est reims il faut savoir
m'a dit un responsable que tant qu on
transportera du pétrole il y aura des
accidents
malgré les précautions prises un
pétrolier ce n'est pas un pinardiers il
ajouté je ne sais pas si on a besoin de
20 mais on a besoin de pétrole
alors on peut retenir que le pétrolier
n'étaient pas équipés du système de
sécurité qui permet de remplacer l'air
dans les cuves par du gaz inerte
un dispositif qui n'est pas obligatoire
26 morts aussi je crois qu'il faut le
rappeler dans l'explosion d'un autre
pétrolier l'andros patriat au large du
portugal
et voilà que malgré les assurances des
pouvoirs publics locaux le pétrole qui
s'est échappé de ses cuves a fini par
atteindre la côte espagnole
neuf jours après l'accident les quelque
soixante mille tonnes de pétrole
échappée des soutes de l'andros patriat
commence à souiller le littoral
depuis hier le vent a tourné il a fait
dériver la nappe de fioul vers les côtes
de la galice en espagne
les habitants de toute la région ont
commencé à nettoyer les plages quant aux
pêcheurs ils ont des raisons d'être
inquiet dans cet endroit
particulièrement poisse au mieux ils ne
comprennent pas l'attitude des autorités
depuis vendredi l'état-major maritimes
de la région a en effet arrêté les
opérations de prévention estimant que
tout danger de marée noire était écarté
le pétrolier gracq et toujours surveillé
par la marine portugaise si le temps le
permet on envisage de transvaser le
reste de la cargaison de langue rose
patriat environ 40 mille tonnes dans les
soutes d'un autre bateau mettant du côté
espagnol que du côté portugais
il semble qu'on ait choisi la solution
la moins risquée celle de la tente et
des images qui nous rappelle quelque
chose
tout comme hier soir le deuxième dossier
chaud de l'actualité reste le cambodge
le nouveau régime s'installe alors que
le canon tonne encore au nord-ouest du
pays à la frontière thaïlandaise ont dit
que l'ancien dictateur polpot premier
mini jusqu'à avant-hier auraient trouvé
la mort sans que ne soit précisé les
conditions de cette disparition
en tout cas sa place aujourd'hui ensam
rim qui est président du conseil
révolutionnaire du peuple du kampuchea
conseil immédiatement reconnue par hanoï
c'est de dire par les vietnamiens qui
ont chaleureusement c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire contribué à son accession au
pouvoir
même chose pour l'urss et pour le laos
alors aussitôt bien sûr on a tout de
suite craint pour l'extension possible
du conflit par exemple entre les deux
super grande l'est la chine et l'urss
mais ce n'est pas pour l'instant les
lymphocytes visiter de se lancer dans
ses initiatives militaires pour diverses
raisons tout d'abord le degré de leur
matériel nucléaire n'est pas suffisant
pour dissuader les soviétiques d'une
intervention non classique
deuxièmement parce que leurs forces
conventionnelles quoique nombreuses sont
dotés d'un matériel déçu est largement
périmés troisièmement parce qu'ils sont
lancés dans leur propre construction
économique en particulier dans la
modernisation de l'industrie et enfin
quatrièmement parce que l'ensemble de
leurs frontières est tout de même
beaucoup plus vive vulnérables qu'on
imagine
oui je pense même que sur les 8000
kilomètres de frontière il doit exister
des points très sensible entre les deux
pays
oui cette frontière au fond est très
varié n'est ce pas un peu je crois
considérer trois éléments la frontière
occidentale c'est à dire le cimetière
qui est peuplée allogènes et
il est très difficile de conduire une
guerre populaire défensive de style
chinois dans cette région de même dans
la partie centrale mongolie extérieure
cette partie est dangereusement proche
de pékin un certain nombre de divisions
blindés soviétiques qui sont concentrées
un coup de main en direction de calgon
est en tout cas la région de pékin n'est
pas du tout impossible n'a également pas
de guerre populaire
et puis troisième région la mandchourie
qui est une région elle très peuple est
avec 50 ou 60 millions d'habitants mais
qui est une région très sensible parce
qu'il rassemble presque la moitié de
l'industrie suédoise
alors je ne pense pas que chinois
puissent se prendre des risques
actuellement est ce que vous ne pensez
tout de même pas que cette affaire
cambodgienne et donc vietnamienne
illustre une escalade entre moscou et
pékin qui pourrait faire que très vite
personne ne pourra plus contrôler la
situation
il ya tout de même un danger sûrement
mais d'autre part les vietnamiens se
sont suffisamment garantis en signant au
mois de novembre dernier 3 novembre si
je me trompe
un traité d'amitié de coopération avec
les soviétiques qui équivaut à une sorte
d'alliance virtuel et ce traité peut
avoir pour effet d'intimider les chinois
faut noter à cet égard à revirements des
chinois l'égard des khmers rouges
pk ne mentionne plus maintenant le nom
de l'équipe de polpot qu'elle avait
pourtant beaucoup aidé en revanche elle
soutient l'action du prince yanouk le
prince qui est toujours à l'heure qu'il
est en route pour new york il a fait
tout à leur escale à tokyo
c'est de là que viennent ces images dans
quelques minutes sur l'avion atterrira
aux états unis il y ait demandé à l'onu
de condamner l'intervention vietnamienne
au cambodge
mais dans le même temps on sait déjà
qu'il continuera critiqué sévèrement
l'ancien régime de pol pot de toute
façon il ne retournera pas au cambodge
peu titre reviendra-t-il à pékin peut
être aussi demandera t-il l'asile
politique en france
il livrait alors dans sa propriété des
alpes maritimes à mougins propriété que
voici
pour l'instant la femme du prince ianu
la princesse monique a pu elle aussi
gagner pékin
en revanche le prince est sans nouvelles
de ses deux filles qui ont été assignés
à résidence dans une coopérative à la
campagne encore un attentat aujourd'hui
à madrid un juge du tribunal suprême de
la ville a été tué ce matin par deux
individus dont le geste n'a ce soit
encore pas été revendiqué et puis un
autre attentat ce matin mais à rome
cette fois c'est le premier de l'année
pour l'italie un commando a fait
irruption dans les locaux de la radio
privée tita photo gr et a ouvert le feu
sur les occupants du studio cinq blessés
l'attentât devait peut appraître
revendiqué par des fascistes
voici donc un nouvel épisode de la
psychose de la peur qui a fini par
gagner les italiens attentats
enlèvements tous les jours ou presque
pourtant certains y trouvent leur compte
je parlais de ces marchands qui font feu
de tout bois regardez l'exemple
anecdotique mais significatif de ces
vendeurs de vêtements blindés
et celle d'un complot dont il est une
balle qui est entré ici et là une autre
vous pouvez constater que de l'autre
côté le gilet est intacte
actuellement en italie et par les temps
qui courent la mode n'a rien à voir avec
la haute couture c'est la mode des
vêtements blindé le tissu n'est pas très
élégant mais efficace il résiste au
brushing 7,65 au parabellum 9 mm au colt
45 et au fait 38
on peut se protéger de la tête au pied
quitte à augmenter son propre poids de
10 kg et à payer quelque 6000 francs il
y a en moyenne 600 demandes de vêtements
blindé par mois ce sont des industriels
des artistes ou des journalistes qui
commande
il y a des commandes très curieuse il y
a des gens qui veulent se protéger la
tête et nous fabriquons des chapeaux
blindés confectionné avec ce tissu
spécial
il y en a qui veulent se protéger les
jambes
pas de problème nous sommes en mesure de
blindés complètement des pantalons
n'oublions pas qu'en italie les
terroristes tirent souvent dans les
jambes pour humilier leurs victimes
en appliquant ce tissu spécial à
l'intérieur des pantalons on aura
quelques difficultés à se déplacer mais
c'est efficace
et au cas où les terroristes seraient de
mauvais tireur autant protégé également
la partie la plus charnue de l'individu
il ya énormément commandes de la part
des gangsters et des délinquants qui
voudraient bien à porter des gilets pare
balles mais nous refusons de livrer sans
l'accord des carabiniers nous
considérons que le gilet est une arme et
quand on reçoit une commande d'un
particulier
on se renseigne auprès des carabiniers
de l'endroit où habitent ce particulier
voilages il est très confortable
c'est très résistant
en somme c'est un retour au moyen-âge au
temps des chevaliers
mais la technique de fabrication des
armures a fait de réels progrès il
arrange on est calme aujourd'hui le
bonnement de monsieur bakhtiar doit
toujours faire face à la double
offensive de l'opposition qu'il a
aujourd'hui récuser plus que jamais et
des partisans de la répression et puis
l'a perdu une pièce dans son dispositif
général jam nouveau ministre de la
défense qui a déjà décidé de
démissionner le minime héros de irakien
à paris aujourd'hui monsieur marouf et
en france pour trois jours visite prévue
de longue date mais qui prend un peu
plus de relief avec les problèmes
d'approvisionnement en pétrole que va
connaître la france si la source
iranienne ce tard ce clip s'assied le
pétrole ne figure pas officiellement au
menu des discussions franco irakienne
est pourtant difficile de penser qu'on
ne parlera pas d'énergie entre ministre
irakien ministre français l'irak qui est
en effet une place importante dans la
stratégie pétrolière de la france c'est
un pays qui peut nous aider à passer
quelques semaines difficiles
si la production iranienne ne
redémarrait pas rapidement étant à paris
la france est le premier acheteur de
pétrole iranien qui représentent environ
20% de nos achats totaux l'irak après
l'arabie saudite est notre deuxième
fournisseur
c'est à peu près le seul pays
susceptibles de nous procurer davantage
de pétrole actuellement et pourparlers
ont lieu en ce moment entre la compagnie
française des pétroles et le
gouvernement irakien pour justement voir
si l'on peut augmenter nos achats de
brut
en effet si la production iranienne
n'avait pas repris au mois de mars
prochain
des risques de pénurie même de hausses
de prix ne sont pas tout à fait à
écarter
sa politique maintenant après
l'entretien à giscard mon roi hier soir
consacre aux problèmes de la région nord
pas de calais vous savez que le conseil
des ministres du 17 janvier adoptera un
programme d'ensemble pour cette région
et bien voici ce matin l'entretien bar
chaban jacques chaban delmas et comme
camon roy président d'un conseil
régional celui là qui peine le plan de
renouveau cette région a été chiffré à
144 millions de francs et 76 mesures sur
lesquelles nous reviendrons car nous
nous entendons parler souvent des
problèmes du grand sud ouest dans son
ensemble puis ce matin en marge de cet
entretien des grévistes de la fp a c'est
à dire l'association pour la formation
professionnelle des adultes ont
manifesté contre le transfert de leur
agence à bordeaux
ils s'inquiètent par ailleurs
d'éventuels licenciements sidérurgie le
parti communiste de son côté appelle à
une grande manifestation le 18 janvier à
paris et puis la politique pure
maintenant avec un nouvel accès de
fièvre sur l'europe au sein du rpr de
déclarations radicalement opposées celle
d'olivier guichard et celle de michel
debré alors d'abord celle de michel
debré
car lancé une campagne axée sur la
révision des traités européens avec à la
clé vous allez le voir une sorte de tact
je propose un pacte un pacte européen
qui non seulement révise modifie des
dispositions caduque absurde mais en
même temps établi sur des bases
convenable la possibilité d'une union
des états respectant l'indépendance et
l'unité de la france c'est-à-dire pour
dire les choses comme elles sont
assurons aux français qu'ils seront
défendus et que leurs intérêts ne seront
pas mis de côté au profit d'intérêts
étrangers en intérêts qui sont
contraires au le parlement qu'on puisse
dire l'année brême c'est que cette
planète et c'est très fort oui nous
avons entendu ce matin michel devrait
des jours les plus enflammés du courrier
de la colère jugés 'sans il veut
continuer sa campagne compte pour la
révision des clauses des traités
européens
pendant les présidentielles il
législatives à venir et jusqu'à son
dernier jour car la supranationalité dit
il est une bête hideuse a écrasé alors
si chirac lui avons-nous dit ne vous
suis pas sur ce terrain
et bien je ferai ma propre liste
et là évidemment il risque d'y avoir
éparpillement des voix et quelques
problèmes pour la liste rpr de monsieur
chirac alors curieusement nous avons
demandé rue glisse qu'elle était la
réaction
officiellement il n'y en a pas mais avec
un certain humour nous fait remarquer
que finalement la position de monsieur
chirac serait finalement beaucoup plus
modérée alors voilà pour ceux qui
trouvent que jacques chirac m'a fait pas
douter il ya aussi ceux qui trouvent que
jacques chirac en fait beaucoup trop
c'est le cas d'olivier guichard qu'il
l'a dit assez vertement dans un article
dans le monde oui dans une analyse assez
poussée alors là il faut noter que
finalement monsieur richard comme
monsieur debré est l'un des barons du
gaullisme
depuis vingt ans ils ont donc suivi le
général de gaulle puis georges pompidou
et monsieur richard contrairement à
monsieur debré estime que le président
de la république d'aujourd'hui est dans
le droit fil de l'action de ses
prédécesseurs en revanche en ce qui
concerne monsieur chirac
eh bien monsieur guy fischer estime
contre le 12 novembre jour d'un congrès
extraordinaire où une motion plus tôt
européenne a été votée et l'appel de
cochin du 6 décembre
eh bien monsieur chirac lui a changé
d'attitude alors ils s'interrogent
pourquoi cette attitude quel est
l'objectif poursuivi
s'agit-il vraiment de politique
européenne ou s'agit-il plutôt de
condamner totalement la politique du
président de la république et monsieur
monsieur richard pardon écrit je cite
s'il s'agit de détourner ces élections
européennes en leur donnant le sens d'un
contre référendum ou d'un contre
plébiscite ou deux contraires aux
institutions eh bien il n'est pas
pensable pour ceux qui les gens pètent
sous-entendu le rpr d'y prêter la main
alors oui on met pas les conséquences à
l'intérêt de la majorité
tout n'est pas simple surtout les
conséquences de l'appel de michel debré
ce matin eh bien le michel debré
évidemment estime que monsieur chirac ne
va pas absolument pas assez loin
que donc il espère entraîner une partie
du rpr c'est tout de même la conscience
du rpm et il est évident que tout même
il peut gêner monsieur chirac et qu'est
ce qu'on pense l'autre aile de la
majorité l'udf cette fois est bien l'udf
monsieur pinton étaient très optimistes
très optimiste tout va très bien madame
la marquise nous at il dit en quelque
sorte car entre les extrêmes et bien
l'udf à des positions raisonnables que
les français comprennent
il n'y a pas d'état d'âme et il a
condamné très serveurs très sévèrement
écouter le monsieur michel debré
économique monsieur michel parent
tout ce que je peux dire c'est que je
trouve ça triste ans si j'ai bien
compris messieurs devraient ils
remettent en cause tous les traités
signés par la france depuis 20 ans ils
remettent en cause la politique suivie
par trois présidents de ligues succès si
vis-à-vis de l'europe depuis vingt ans
les me manque un peu pour savoir qu'en
penser de deux choses l'une ou bien
monsieur devrait fait partie de la
majorité présidentielle auquel cas il
faut qu'il se plie qui est acceptée par
une majorité présidentielle où il
considère qu'il faut pas partie et alors
pourquoi il ya quelques mois at-il voulu
être candidat unique cette majorité
présidentielle dans ces circonscriptions
j'ajoute que du côté du df le michel
prix de ce qui revient officiellement
sur la scène politique il vient d'entrer
au conseil de l'udf qui désormais
comprendra 19 membres fantastique c'est
le même épithètes en anglais fantastique
pour qualifier les photos de jupiter que
vient de recevoir la nasa elles sont
pourtant blasé ses techniciens
américains qui ont déjà disséqué
d'autres planètes comme mars ou vénus
par exemple et pourtant la sonde
voyageurs un qui a permis cet exploit
est encore à s'éloigner de jupiter un
peu moins de 60 millions de kilomètres
elle ne l'a survolera vraiment de près
que le 5 mars prochain
effectivement moi si jupiter vu par
voyageur un cette planète la plus grosse
du système solaire possède une tâche
rouge extrêmement curieuse trois fois
plus grande que la terre cela vous donne
une
des dimensions de l'ast ces photos
montrent aux techniciens qui savait
déchiffrer que jupiter n'a pas de sol
solide et composée surtout d'hydrogène
et ressemble finalement à un oeuf de
pâques
l'engin qui prend ces photos c'est
voyagera un vaisseau explorateur
américain automatique et très
perfectionné créé vitesse actuelle par
rapport à la terre et de 70 mille
kilomètres à l'heure soit paris lyon en
20 secondes
malgré cette vitesse il reste encore
deux mois de voyage pour se trouver dans
la banlieue de jupiter et photographié
en gros plan cette fois ci la planète
ainsi que les satellites naturels qui
tourne autour d'elle ces ateliers sont
très particulier puisque certains ne
sont pas constitués de rochers et de
glace après cela ce sera saturn fin 80
et si tout va bien
uranus trois ans plus tard de dépêches
de la minute pendant jupiter d'abord la
naissance de quintupler à nancy les
quintuples est donc née il y à quelques
minutes la maternité de nancy leurs
parents son fleuriste et la mer et est
hospitalisé depuis quelques semaines car
on savait qu'elle attendait des
quintuplés et puis j'apprends que pour
par les élections européennes dont nous
parlions tout est là avec daniel bryan
le groupe communiste de l'assemblée
nationale vient de demander la confiance
la convocation d'une séance
extraordinaire de l'assemblée deux
doigts des sports maintenant avec tout
d'abord en rugby la composition de
l'équipe de france qui affrontera
l'irlande à dublin dans une dizaine de
jours pour son premier match du tournoi
des cinq nations
vous devriez en voir la composition sur
votre écran vous neutre et le rappel du
troisième ligne de toulon alain guilbert
qui ne s'attendait pas du tout
d'ailleurs à être rappelés ils pensaient
qu'ils avaient été très mauvais dans les
derniers matchs et puis du trois quarts
aile bilbao voilà ce qui maintenant à
crans montana en suisse pour le slalom
spécial on attendait le sud-ouest et mme
marc hé bien ce fut un revenant qui
l'emporta l'autrichien christian
neureuther qui a gagné devant un bulgare
qui fait de plus en plus parler lui
retenez bien son nom
pop angelov le tout en images c'est
décidément la chute des idoles il ya
quelques jours la fin si votre chien
clamait retombe en descente à morzine ce
matin à crans montana en suisse autour
du suédois stenmark numéro un en slalom
spécial
un accident peu
être en tout cas un curieux début
d'année en ski car le vainqueur du
spécial ce matin est un certain angle
rue terre qui n'est pas de la première
jeunesse
il a 30 ans et cela fait plus de dix ans
qu'ils usent des skis sur toutes les
pistes du monde classée huitième
seulement de la première manche
l'allemand est parvenu à retourner la
situation grâce à un second parcours
en tout point remarquable non ils
réitèrent prive la bulgarie d'un premier
succès en coupe du monde en la personne
de pape angelov deuxième à 18 centièmes
de secondes c'est vrai retenez le nom de
ce jeune bulgare pape angelov carnoye
rueters est tout de même déjà du passé
et puis il a d'autres soucis en tête
qu'il doit épouser prochainement la
jolie rosie mi temps mais hier un homme
heureux
la rte
disparition d'un des pères du jazz
moderne charlie mingus est mort il ya
quatre jours au mexique des suites d'une
maladie musculaire ce contrebassiste
hors pair a mis des amstrong et votre
grand avait traversé les modes en
caressant de son archet le blues et le
gospel charlie minus avait 56 ans
hemming les années 60 a été l'ouverture
le free jazz mais aussi le retour de la
musique sur dick à des conceptions
presque sociologique c'est lui qui a
commencé par dire je suis noir suis
malheureux etc
mais j'ai aussi je suis aussi noir et je
suis aussi le fils spirituel duke
ellington rassemblons tous à la musique
de newton la musique d'église la musique
de gospel tout ça et si on ne ferait que
la technique toute cette toutes ses
improvisations tout ce déchaînement dans
une musique nouvelle c'est pour 5000 us
a révélé des improvisateurs
extraordinaire comme eric dolphy
notamment comme jacky bailleur face et a
vraiment un créateur extraordinaire
nous
il
g
ou seulement se perdent leur sens même
changé
m
la main
abandon
charlet minus à ce chapitre disparition
j'ajoute que les obstacles général
vanuxem décédé avant-hier seront
célébrer après demain en l'église des
invalides à paris
la page de la météo avec tout d'abord un
rapide survol de la situation le mauvais
temps est encore la cause de pas mal de
dommages dans notre pays en moselle 300
familles privées de chauffage à forbach
neige verglas et bouchons ce matin sur
les routes de la région parisienne et
puis dans l'orléanais
l'armée est intervenue pour lutter
contre l'enneigement est dans les halles
et bien les récentes chutes de neige
laisse craindre des risques d'avalanche
cela dit aujourd'hui l'heureux doux a
annoncé est arrivé tout timidement vous
le voyez avec un temps couvert et
pluvieux sur presque tout le pays un peu
moins froid quand même c'est vrai demain
quelques gelées nocturnes dans le centre
et dans le nord-est dans la journée
pluies dans le sud ailleurs temps
variable avec des éclaircies malgré tous
ces nuages noirs quelques averses près
de la manche vers 23h35 avec l'autre
prendra mon relais pour vous présenter
le dernier journal n'oubliez pas demain
12h la première édition de notre
ensemble d'informations sur antenne 2
avec antenne de midi point final de la
présidente édition je vous remercie de
votre attention
et puis je vous souhaite une excellente
fin de soirée demain